secretaries of State Lincoln and vilsack
members of Congress ambassadors members
of both houses MEPS mlas MPS members of
the Biden family and distinguished
guests
and I think I must mention somebody else
Mr President because it's just come to
my attention that a very young Observer
is in attendance here today and that is
the daughter of Senator Rebecca Rebecca
Moynihan our infant daughter Margo and
and I do suspect that Margo's attendance
here will go down in family folklore for
many years to come
forward
President Biden you are most welcome to
Leinster House the home of our national
Parliament this is a very proud and
historic day for us all it is a day we
have looked forward to since your
election on the 40s as the 46th
president of the United States just over
two years ago
today you do us the honor of addressing
our joint sitting it's the fourth time
the houses have been addressed by a U.S
president
almost 60 years ago on the 28th of June
1963 in a very different world and a
very different Ireland the late
President John F Kennedy addressed the
houses and inspired our people
it is particularly fitting therefore
that you should address us so close to
that important anniversary
today we acknowledge the presence in
Ireland of his granular nephew Joseph
Kennedy III the new U.S economic Envoy
to Northern Ireland and we wish him
every success in the important role of
supporting peace and prosperity that you
have assigned to him
thank you
now Mr President while all previous
presidential addresses have been of
major significance
today's is like no other
because amongst an extensive list of
distinguished guests we're joined here
in the doll today by our former
illustrious president Mary mcaleese
former tishuk bertia her in a key
architect of the Good Friday agreement
former teacher Kenny a fellow male man
and a close personal friend we know of
yours
joining us also is the former president
of shin Fein and a former member of this
house Jerry Adams who played such a key
role in The Good Friday agreement
negotiations and from north of the
Border we also welcome Alex maskey
speaker of the northern assembly which
I'm sure you would have liked to have
been able to address Michelle O'Neill
the Northern Leader of shin Fane
Colony stood Member of Parliament leader
of the sdlp and a successor to the great
John Hume Nobel Peace Laureate and an
initiator of the Good Friday peace
agreement and Naomi long leader of the
very Progressive and growing Alliance
party
I extend a special welcome also to miss
Murray uh Heaney whose late husband
sheamusini is a favorite poet of yours
Mr President and have ours also and
thank you
a Nobel Prize winner and one of our
great literary Treasures
Sheamus would have been 84 today
and I'm sure he is looking down on us
with his glasses nestled between his
fingers and a hint of a smile on his
face
from The Diplomatic core I warmly
welcome the U.S ambassador Claire Cronin
thank you for sending her to us and her
Irish counterparts
an Irish counterpart in Washington
Ambassador Geraldine Byrne Nason one of
the very best
these two outstanding women have done
our two countries proud
we are joined too by the dean of the
Diplomatic Corps the remark the Moroccan
ambassador to Ireland the representative
of the European commission and
Parliament Jonathan Claridge and finula
croker our dear neighbor and friend
Ambassador Paul Johnson of the United
Kingdom
but may I extend a very spot special and
warm welcome to the much admired
Ukrainian ambassador to Ireland someone
who has become incredibly well known to
all of us Larissa Carrasco Above All
Else represents the nearly 80
000 displaced Ukrainian citizens now
resident in Ireland
so for you Mr President quite a
gathering
and with the greatest of respect Mr
President I must say you sure can draw a
crowd
perhaps afterwards you might give me
some hints on how we could ensure a good
attendance around here on Thursday
afternoon
President Biden today you're amongst
friends because you are one of us
you often speak of your Irish roots with
great pride and affection especially
your ancestors from Laos and mayo and
the story of Ireland is inextricably
linked to immigration and in many ways
you personify it
from the famine times through to today
so many people left these Shores in
search of a better life in the United
States and a remarkable 33 maybe 34
million Americans now claim Irish
ancestry
the signatories of the 1916 Proclamation
said that this very Republic came into
being with the support and I quote of
its exiled children in America
and how true that was
down through the years our Exiles
supported Ireland economically and
politically and never forgot the
families they left behind all through
your political career sir you too have
been a faithful and supportive friend of
Ireland you have been there to quote the
well-known song in sunshine or in Shadow
so on this historic occasion you're
homecoming we warmly welcome you back to
your roots from the bottom of our hearts
we thank you for all you have done and
continue to do for us here in Ireland
the Ireland you are visiting this week
is a multicultural Progressive Nation
benefiting enormously from an inflow of
immigrants who have arrived on our
Shores from across the world they enrich
our society and help us grow our economy
just like the Irish did and many other
nations in the United States in Years
Gone by they also challenge all of us
all of us
to be better than we are and better than
we think we can be
our two countries enjoy a warm close and
mutually beneficial relationship it has
been an enduring relationship built on
shared values and shared economic
interests as well as a passion for
politics and a love of culture matters
that you have highlighted Mr President
frequently economically Ireland has
benefited immensely from U.S investment
which supports over 370 000 jobs in
Ireland today as a result we now have
thriving technology Healthcare and
financial services sectors less spoken
about however Mr President are the 650
plus Irish companies
that operate across all 50 states of the
Union employing over a hundred thousand
people and the fact that Ireland today
is the ninth largest source of foreign
direct investment in the United States
long may this bilateral investment
continue
Mr President two years ago on a cold
January day in Washington D.C you spoke
of the importance of unity
and Hope
and As We Gather in this Easter week we
recognize that the world is in need of
Hope
for those affected by War hope for those
suffering from hunger and hope for those
in the face of the exist the existential
threat of climate change
on this island your visit to Northern
Ireland is an important statement of
Hope and support for building a better
and continued peaceful and prosperous
future for all
we thank you for your own stinting and
constructive support for the Good Friday
agreement over the last 25 years and for
your continued close engagement which
you demonstrated so powerfully this week
friends and colleagues politics despite
what the six might say is a noble
profession and we are fortunate today to
welcome not just a very fine politician
but an outstanding and international
Statesman
President Biden in life you have
demonstrated unshakable Faith deep
resilience and the ability to bring
people of diverse and often conflicting
views together
above all the quote the memorable words
of the iconic Sheamus Heaney
you challenge us to believe
that the farther Shore is reachable I
invite you now to address the houses
thank you
well Mom
you said it would happen
and Margot I apologize to you little
baby girl
the idea you're subject to hearing the
president United States have to deliver
a policy speech
is as bad as my all my children have had
been put through
speaking to my children my son Hunter's
with me and my best friend in the world
my sister Valerie's with me today and I
want them to
foreign
[Music]
as the proud son of Catherine Eugenia
Finnigan Biden
well
you knew I'd be coming
speaker chair
s all and I Deputy Prime Minister TD
Senators people of Ireland it's so good
to be back in Ireland if you forgive the
poor attempted Irish
I'm at home
I only wish I could stay longer
but I always have a little bit of
Ireland close by even when I'm in
Washington in the Oval Office I have the
rugby ball signed by the Irish Rugby
team the ball the team played when they
beat the All Blacks
by the way
my cousin one of Ireland's greatest
rugby Stars Rob Kearney
brought it to D.C on St Patrick's Day in
2022 to give me and I didn't play rugby
except when I was out of school out of
law school and I didn't play it very
well we played in a rugby club but I did
play American football in a few other
sports but I realized that you know you
guys are all nuts you know but the
interesting thing is I'd rather have my
children playing rugby now for health
reasons than I would have them playing
football fewer people get hurt playing
rugby and you have no equipment you have
280 pound guys like we do and you just
don't hit each other's head very often
and uh but anyway it all kidding aside I
in 2016 I came to Ireland as vice
president bringing most of my family
with me my sister Valerie my brother
Jimmy my daughter and my five
granddaughters and grandchildren my
granddaughters are crazy about me and my
dad because I talk to them every single
day I send them a note together we
explored our family history visiting
through the Coulee peninsula where the
Finnegan's ancestors earned their living
on land and in Sea and walking the
streets of balm where my great great
great grandfather blew it lived with his
family before relocated in 1851
eventually settling in my hometown of
Scranton Pennsylvania
yesterday I returned to County louth
where I toured the calling for Castle
likely one of the last Clemsons of
Ireland my Finnegan ancestors saw as
they gazed on their way out and when in
those days was referred to as a coffin
ship and they sailed out a Newry in
1850. I wasn't going to say this but
I'll say it anyway the idea was I later
learned from the Irish Times They did
some little background check and my good
friend Barack Obama and is my good
friend his grandfather was a Shoemaker
like mine sailed five weeks earlier from
the same port
the idea they both sail for a new life
and thought their grandchildren their
great great grandsons would both be
present I think is really a little bit
of Irish Malarkey but
[Music]
tomorrow
I'll also revisit County Mayo remember
the history and hope and the Heartbreak
of my blue and ancestors must have felt
leaving their beloved Homeland to begin
the new lives in America
I sell this not to wax poetic about
bygone days but because of the story of
my family's journey and those who left
and those who stayed is emblematic of
the stories of so many Irish and
American families not just
irish-american families and these
stories are the very heart of what binds
Ireland and America together
they speak to a history defined by our
dreams they speak to A Present written
by our shared responsibility and they
speak to a future poised for unlimited
shared possibilities so today I'd like
to reflect on the enduring strength of
the connections between Ireland and the
United States a partnership for the ages
begins in our shared history dating back
to the very founding of the United
States
the Irish hearts that helped Kindle the
torch of Liberty in my country and fire
its revolutionary Spirit the Irish blood
from across this island that was
willingly given for my country's
Independence
the Irish hands that laid the
foundations of a new kind of future
one from the bottom up in the middle out
one built on freedom
you know the great ways immigration that
brought our ancestors to the United
States and succeeding decades carried
Millions more Irishmen across the sea
most of them arrived a little more than
with hope in their hearts and strengthen
their dreams and beautiful memories of
an emerald green Isle a home they would
never fully leave behind
I've never met an Irishman in America
doesn't think you know hope we can see
Ireland someday
you know they're sweet they're excuse me
their sweat is soaked with the
foundations of communities Across the
Nation all across America you can't go
anywhere and not find it by the way Tip
O'Neill a former Speaker of the House
used to say that he'd have a he'd have a
a reception for all the Irish and the
Congress the house and the Senate and
all those who wish they were Irish and
everybody showed up
look
the journeys of our ancestors expanded
our Horizons and literally excited our
imaginations
they became the untiring backbone of
America's progress as a nation even as
they endured discrimination and they
were denied opportunity I'll tell you a
story I was campaigning for president
and I was out in Colorado and I was with
a man whose family had been he was a
former Senator a man whose family had
been in the United States since the
Conquistadors for generations and he
kept in there a whole lot of people
standing across a refurbished rail
station in Western and excuse me in
eastern Colorado and there was literally
ten thousand people on the other side of
the track waiting to hear me speak and
he kept saying now Joe remember remember
these people were not these are my
people they're Hispanic they're not used
to being taking you got to show respect
and Syria I said I understand he kept
kept it up finally I turned Mr God's
truth this refurbished train station
okay
it had like linen kind of wallpaper on
it and about every 20 feet there was a
brass plaque that's saying no Irish
allowed
I said I get it
I get it but it's history to speak above
all to the values of sustain these
people throughout their hardships in
their lives
Freedom equality dignity
family
courage
my mom used to have an expression of
Joey courage is the greatest virtue of
all for without courage you can't love
with abandon
without courage you cannot love with
abandon
these are the values that were handed
down generation and generation in my
family
grafted onto the American character
tended as they transformed an entire
nation
like so many countries around the world
though perhaps more than most the United
States was shaped by Ireland and that's
not hyperbole that's a fact
and the values we share remain to this
day the core of our historic partnership
between our people and our governments
as Nations we've known hardship and
division we've also found solace in
sympathy in one another in just four
years before we issued our Declaration
of Independence Benjamin Franklin came
to the Irish Parliament and declared and
described it as I quote disposed to be
friends of America end of quote
and turn the next Ireland to turn the
text of Ireland's 1916 Proclamation
displayed mainly in the main foyer of
this building draws on the support of
Ireland's exiled children in America
quote draws on the support of exiled
children in America
where Nations that know what it means to
persevere for freedom to Brave a civil
war to toil and The Vineyards of
democracy and that's again not hyperbole
it's a fact it's a fact
it's not just the hope
but the conviction that better days lie
ahead and brought us along
we have the power to build a better
future
60 years ago was referenced the first
Irish Catholic President of the United
States made a historic trip here
speaking to this assembly and capturing
the imaginations of Irish and
irish-american families alike
when John Kennedy addressed Parliament
he honored the more than 150 000 Irish
immigrants who joined the army of the
North
during America's Civil War
and among them one or two of them were
my relatives as well
they signed up in a new land to stand
for all values
to defend freedom and the Dignity of all
people think about this name another
country and whatever their language is
that use the word dignity
as much as we Irish use the word dignity
it matters my dad you say everybody Joey
everybody
he meant it it's entitled to be treated
as dignity no matter who they are
President Kennedy honored their courage
and Sacrifice by presenting to this body
the flag of the Irish Brigade which
hangs out here to this very day
like why I was honored received an Irish
flag from the T-shirt during the recent
St Patrick's Day celebration in
Washington it was flown to commemorate
the Irish who first raised the tri-color
in Ireland 175 years ago and who suppose
subsequently made his way to America
where he led the Irish Brigade in that
Civil War that Civil War battle
these liked symbols holding a place of
honor in Leinster House in the White
House embodies Century of history
between our countries
connections that have revocably have
shaped the understanding of the world
and our hope that we put in it
our history reminds us
our history ours yours and mine reminds
us of the responsibilities we have to
the president that should be the
president
to the hopes of our ancestors to the
expectation of future Generations
because you know what it means to fight
for democracy today
Ireland United States are standing
together to pose Russia's brutal
aggression and support the brave people
of Ukraine
I spent many days in Ukraine
[Music]
President Kennedy said 60 years ago and
I quote Ireland pursues an independent
course in foreign policy but it is not
neutral between Liberty and tyranny and
it never will be thank you for that
over the past year Ireland has proved
him right
and speaker said Ireland has stood
proudly with the United States and
partners around the world for Liberty
against tyranny Ireland has committed
more than 170 million euros in
non-lethal Aid Ukraine in looting
including vital protective gear medical
equipment humanitarian support and Aid
to minimize the impacts of War on food
insecurity and child malnutrition
you don't forget
you have memories that go deep
and as a member of the European Union
Ireland is working together the United
States and other partners the whole
Russia accountable for its actions
including through significant sanctions
and Export controls
I've known Putin for over 25 years
Putin thought the world would look the
other way
was confident he would break nato in the
European Union
the unity of Western nations would
fracture and fall at the moment of
testing that's what he thought
but he was wrong he was wrong on every
point and every front today we're more
united and more determined than ever to
defend the values that make us strong
and I want to sincerely thank you for
Ireland's vital leadership last year in
the U.S and U.N security Council working
together Ireland and the United States
helped change the way the U.N sanctions
are implemented to ensure they do not
hamper humanitarian efforts the new
humanitarian carve out will make
sanctions more effective and save lives
Ireland's support for Ukraine is
especially meaningful because you carry
the moral Authority with Nations around
the world
Ireland Ireland's always been a voice
for Liberty Global cooperation and the
quality of all mankind because Ireland
remembers the terrible cost of War
you've built an international
credibility as peacekeepers stepping up
continuously to serve in the U.N keeping
missions since Ireland's First
Development since iron's first
deployment in 1958.
because Ireland remembers
what it means to have to flee home
leaving everything behind and begin
again on foreign Shores the Irish people
have generously opened their hearts
their homes and you welcome as you said
nearly eighty thousand nearly 80 000
Ukrainian refugees I would argue the
rest of the world has an obligation to
help you maintain that as well because
Island remembers how painful Hollows of
the great hunger
and you're today Global leader in food
security as well
Ireland's committed fully 20 percent of
your Aid budget to fighting Global
hunger and in a moment where people
around the world are struggling with the
economic Fallout of the pandemic
Russia's war in Ukraine Ireland is
growing its age budget and expanding its
commitment to helping vulnerable people
especially partner Nations across Africa
I particularly want to thank you for
stepping up alongside the United States
to help UNICEF and the World Health
Organization fight malnutrition and
child wasting Ireland's contribution of
50 million euros is helping prevent the
the the the the and treat wasting child
wasting and Supply ready to use
therapeutic foods and reach a half a
million children in Africa a half a
million children
you're changing lives
Ireland also remembers as I do that
peace is indispensable
peace is the necessary foundation for
Progress for both for growth for
unlocking the enormous potential that
exists in every part of this island
this week marks a vital milestone for
peace
25 years ago the Belfast Good Friday
agreement
25 years ago one of my best friends in
the Senate a great great friend to this
day is George Mitchell as he said there
were 300 days of failure or 700 days of
failure and one day of success
but it was a success that one day but
more is to be done
yesterday I was in Belfast to honor
Those who commit themselves to peace to
reiterate the endurance supporting the
United States for the Good Friday
agreement and Northern Ireland's
Democratic institutions
and to help accelerate the enormous
economic growth that is opening new
futures for young people in Northern
Ireland as I pointed out
there are literally hundreds of American
corporations ready to come and invest
invest but they're cautious
because the institutions are not a place
we must never forget that peace even as
has become
and lived reality for entire generation
of young people peace is precious
it still needs its champions
it still needs to be nurtured
The Good Friday agreement didn't change
just change lives for the better
Northern Ireland that significant
positive impact across the Republic of
Ireland as well
as a teacher and I have discussed
including last month in Washington and
again today how Ireland and the United
States can work together with the United
Kingdom and the European Union to
support the people of Northern Ireland
I think I think
that the United Kingdom should be
working closer with Ireland in this ever
this endeavor political violence must
never again be allowed to take hold in
this island
[Music]
presumption me to say from the United
States but that must be the goal which
guides Us in all our efforts
because the greatest peace dividend with
a good Friday agreement
is an entire generation of young people
entire generation young people
his Hearts have been shaped not by
grievances of the past
but by confidence
that there are no checkpoints on their
dreams
they're writing a new future the future
of unlimited possibilities
for too long
Ireland has talked about
in the past in the past tense
we tell all stories of days gone by
is good to remember
stories of irish-gritten Genius Saints
and Scholars poets and politicians
and in the face of it they're good
stories on his face let's face it but
as the poet Bolin wrote in her poem
Mother Ireland she said I've learned my
name I Rise though I rose up I
remembered it now now I can tell my
story it was different from the stories
told about me end of quote
today Ireland's story is no one's to
tell but it's own
but the United States will be your
closest partner your most Dependable
partner and your most enthusiastic
supporter of every step of the way I
promise you
we've always been and we've been
together
and we're going to continue to grow our
enormous economic relationship as a
foundation for both our nation's
prosperity
we're going to continue to strengthen
our economies building them from the
bottom up in the middle out
yesterday and always already Ireland
draws its disproportionate amount of
foreign direct investment from the
United States of America
the same is true for Ireland's
investment into the United States of
America which is the ninth most
significant investment of any nation in
the world in America
you know we share more than one trillion
dollars in bilateral trade and
investment in 2021 more than 950
American companies and their National
companies have international
headquarters in Ireland
supporting hundreds of thousands of jobs
700 Irish companies located in 50 states
employ more than 100 000 people in the
United States of America
and together our island of the United
States are building the future of
Greater economic dignity one where
rights of workers are respected and
corporations pay their fair share
thank you
the global minimum tax will continue
Fair competition for investing while
creating benefits for all our people and
I have no doubt that the thriving
economic commission between our
countries is going to continue to grow
I'm grateful for Ireland's partnership
in delivering the game change this game
changing International agreement
similarly
the Deep connection has always existed
to between our people in the land has
translated into a commitment to fight
climate crisis to preserve our planet
for future Generations
the single existential threat to the
world
is climate change
we don't have a lot of time and that's a
fact
or even recognizing finally oh
everyone's recognizing America
I've flown over more territory in the
United States since I've been president
of the helicopter that has been burned
to the ground and comprises the entire
state of Maryland
equal to the entire state of Maryland
Ireland's famous Forty Shades of Green
are being supplemented by Green energy
green agriculture green jobs
make no mistake the entire world sees
and is drawn to the opportunities that
exist on this island
skilled workers the high-tech
infrastructure innovators who are
breaking barriers the connection and
kinship you share not just the United
States and the countries around the
globe
I know you all know it maybe sometimes
we forget it Ireland is a hotbed of
Cutting Edge science research and
emerging technologist can influence so
much of our shared future for real
working in partnership with Ireland the
United States
together the European Union and
like-minded parties around the world are
going to ensure that those Technologies
are grounded in the same core values we
have championed for so long democracy
human rights freedom of opportunity
for everyone not just for some for
everyone
you know
I hadn't planned on running for
president again in
2020.
my son Beau had just died of cleop stage
four Global Stone after coming back from
Iraq after a year
's Attorney General of Delaware
as a matter of fact he should be the one
standing here giving the speech to you
but you know
um
I started to write a book talking about
how technology has always changed the
world and we were in an inflection point
in the world
the technology was changing so rapidly
and things were changing so
significantly
that it wasn't so much who led any
country it was the changes that are just
happening at an incredible speed
incredible speed
look what's happening with artificial
intelligence right now
it pulls enormous promise and enormous
concern
our our world stands at an inflection
point
where the choices we make today
are literally going to determine the
future or the history of this world for
the next four to five decades
literally not figuratively we're at one
of those points I had a professor at
school said an inflection point is when
you're riding down the highway at 60
miles an hour and you make a radical
turn six degrees in One Direction you
can never get back in the course you're
on
that's who we are as a world
and as we meet these ageless struggles
they continue to cast a shadow on our
world
struggle between the rights of many and
the desires of a few
between Liberty and oppression and I
know I get criticize for Satanist around
the world but between democracy and
autocracy
it is a competition that's real
and we're called to this work just as
every generation before us has been in
this moment the world needs Ireland and
the United States and our Limitless
imaginations
I meant more with Xi Jinping than any
world leader has over the last 10 years
excuse me 91 hours of just one-on-one
conversations 68 in person I've traveled
17 000 miles with them
through Asia primarily through China
he once asked me that Tibetan Plateau he
said can you define America for me
it's the God's truth
I said yes I can in one word
if he asked me what Ireland could have
said the same thing
one word
possibilities we believe anything is
possible we set our mind to it and we do
it together this is the United States of
America and Ireland there's nothing
beyond our capacity if we do it together
and we've got to believe that we got to
know that because that's the history of
both our countries this is about
defending the values handed down to us
by our ancestors keeping the flame of
Freedom We inherited the beacon that's
going to guide our children and
grandchildren it's a struggle we have to
we're fit to fight together
now how is Ireland United States
now is their time to meet every
challenge together I really mean this
to raise together to rise up
in our Joys and our triumphs
to preserve together
and persevere through sorrows and
setbacks
to dream together over Horizons we can't
see
and to build together a future that may
be that doesn't exist
the future that can be
you know
as is mentioned as today's sheamusini's
birthday
and uh I was always quoting Irish poetry
in the United States Senate over my
career
it's a long career 36 years
and my colleagues always thought I did
it because I was Irish that's not the
reason
the best poets in the world
but we're on the best among them
was your husband
and thank you for sending me that
autograph cup
who's your husband
my favorite poem
was a cure Troy
and uh
and it goes you all know the words you
know I just heard it so many times
he wrote
don't hope
on this side of the grave
but then
once in a lifetime that Long Ford tidal
wave of Justice can rise up
and hope and history rhyme
it's everything I've been taught
rise up
we've been the past made hope in history
rhyme
so today's ladies and gentlemen
as we celebrate the enduring partnership
between our Nations
our shared past our present
let's set our eyes squarely on the
future
let's harness what's Best in US
our courage
our creativity
our loyalty our tenacity
and our loyalty again
let's once more
for our generation and generation to
come
strive to make hope and history rhyme
because I've never been more optimistic
about the future that I'm today
and I'm at the end of my career not the
beginning
the only thing I bring to this career
after my age as you can see how old I am
a little bit of wisdom
I come to the job with more experience
than any president of American History
doesn't make me better or worse
but it gives me a few excuses
Mr folks
it's one of the great honors of my
career
better be here today
and I mean it from the bottom of my
heart
you have no idea
what this my greatest regret I'm going
to sound like a kid but my mom's not
here to hear it
my greatest regret is my grandfather
Finnegan who was a an Irish American
who's a grandfather was Owen Finnegan
who made the effort
and he was a great athlete I went to
Santa Clara University and he was a
newspaper guy on the business side
and I never understood what he meant
when he said Joey
I worry about you you lean over I say
pop what do you worry about he said
you're too much
you're too much like that guy who led
the revolution instead of the guy who
was the Prime Minister
who's he said you got to be less like
a military guy they shot him they're
more like more like Diva Lara
well I've never
but
folks I really mean we can do so much
we really got we can we can't
and it doesn't even break down an
ideology
breaks down on faith in ourselves our
values
because no matter what party we belong
to
our values are the same
it's but honesty dignity
Justice
and you all have every ingredient to
make it work
s it's an honor to be here thank you
very much
foreign